I never really tried to like I don't
really care you know I don't really care
what people's opinions are about stuff
but I don't know they probably do think
about that stuff but the thing is that a
lot of my music is is from it's
heartfelt and it's real but then there's
a lot of my music that's completely
fictional and you know me as a character
which is just like a fun way to write
like I just really enjoy putting myself
in a place that I would never normally
be or that I never will be or never was
you know what I mean
so just to become somebody that you're
not is kind of interesting and writing a
song you don't have to go through what
you're writing about to write about it
which i think is kind of interesting and
people don't really think about that a
lot you know so I try to take advantage
of that how do you just write your sound
because I mean seeing you and hearing
your voice are two totally different
things yet they work so well together
yeah so how do you describe your sound
to maybe someone who hasn't heard it I
never I never know how to describe it
because I don't I don't have a sound and
I feel like the people who think I do
have a sound are wrong I feel like if
you think I have a sound like don't
listen anymore cuz I don't I don't want
to fit into a box I don't want to be a
genre I think like I say all the time
like if it's a good song it's a good
song it doesn't matter where it fits you
know if you like it you like it you know
so I have no idea I think it's it's for
the listener to decide kind of I know
Washington past interviews and listen to
your stuff and looking at yourself by
but you are an artisan somebody
really gets inspiration from anything
you can get inspiration from a bag like
you were saying in one thing you did an
inspiration from a person from a friend
but what really stood out to me is that
so many people want to focus on you
being 16 I know make 16 at this point
your life and being in this career is
that frustrating that so many people
want to focus and that and maybe take
away from the bigger picture of things I
mean I get it it's understandable I mean
I feel like automatically when you hear
somebody's age you want to know how I
mean even I when I meet I don't know
it's weird like you just kind of get
lucky you don't think of it from their
point of view so I get it and it's
understandable and it's cool like people
think I'm cooler for being younger and
being good at stuff or like to them
being good at it I'm just like I think
age doesn't matter at all you could be
good at whatever whenever you know like
and it's the same with pain you can feel
any pain at any point in your life it
doesn't matter like the amount of the
amount of heartbreak that a toddler can
feel you know if you trip and you scrape
your knee that your whole day is like
your heart is broken dude like so for
somebody to say that that somebody can't
be upset or sad or depressed at a young
age it's just ridiculous you know there
and especially now with like
everything's so reachable like the
Internet is so right there it's just
like I don't know so I I think it's like
it's weird cuz people are sometimes
surprised that I'm 16 and I'm like are
you kidding me like there's so many like
14 like 13 6 15 16 year-olds that are
like incredible at what they love why is
it surprising to you you know there's so
many that are just like bomb
[Music]
we'll check it rolling
sorry I just don't want to take away
from you yeah now that you've had the
opportunity to re work with some pretty
incredible artists I was like I thought
I was a person
collaboration what was how did that
happen in what was that like um
Khalid well that was such a such a
genuine thing man like because I
remember hearing location basically
right when it came out in 2016 I don't
remember when it came out but I remember
hearing it right when it came out on
like SoundCloud I remember being like
whoo and I looked up his name on like
apple Spotify nothing at all
literally absolutely nothing and then it
was only on soundcloud whatever and then
I looked up his name on Twitter and he
already had followed me and I was like
oh I was crazy and then he DM me he was
like he was like I'm such a fan of yours
like ocean ice is so beautiful
here's my number and we started talking
and at the time he lived in El Paso but
he was gonna move to LA soon so he was
just like I don't have friends out there
really but um we should hang out and
then he of course became
him which was obviously gonna happen
like it was so clear to everybody around
him but he just I mean lovely came about
just because he I was just like come
over him my brother and me we just sat
at my brother's room we just wrote the
song and it wasn't really like plan that
wasn't like a session it wasn't really
anything it was just let's hang out with
this friend that's just genuinely our
friend and create with him you know
it was really like it was real I mean
there's tons of people I would love to
collaborate with but I don't know I
think it's it should be a natural thing
you know I don't I want to kind of
create music with people that I
genuinely F with you know like just
genuinely we just vibe with each other
you know I don't really want to force
anything but I mean there are tons I
feel like if I'm being like real about
like who my twelve-year-old self or like
my my younger self would just like die
to work with now is like Tyler you know
childish can be you know I don't know of
course Ilana when I was like 12 just
like a lot of people that I would have
died sit but I mean now it's like there
are a lot of artists that are kind of
underground that I just think are sick
like sick there's like Luke Haley 47 and
Jean Doe or whatever she's fire Cimino
moses omni Crookes all these different
artists that like Terrell whack oh my
god
I dude music is so good
what interests me like like
hearing that reason why you made it like
don't smile at mm-hmm
is and I know like you've always wanted
this and you said you always wanna be
famous like not famous but you wanted to
do this and be a part of this and
perform and and be in concerts and have
people come out and listen to you but
Fame is such a different concept than
all that fame is like something that you
can't even explain all some people want
your photo people screaming you got
another cars you want to know about your
business is that everything that you
thought it was gonna be no no no um no
it's it's weird dude like Fame is
disgusting horrible gross throw up blah
but the reason that all of that is worth
it is so that I can do these shows with
that audience oh my god that's like
priceless you can't even I and I would
not I would never be able to get that
experience without the miserable aspect
of my life
you know and it sounds so annoying
because it's like people you know I
worked really hard to get here and I'm
here and it's like I'm really grateful
and I am but you know there are a lot of
things that people don't know about
until you're in them and then you
understand I mean growing up if I heard
somebody who was like where I am right
now say this kind of thing I'd be like
what like come on but you don't
understand until you understand and then
it's completely different I don't know
but it's it's a beautiful thing to get
to perform and be in
and like meet all of those kids outside
like I just want to go out there right
now and just like go eat some pizza with
them you know